[Musica]
buonasera a tutti
mi presento mi chiamo benedetta de luca
o 30 anni sono una dottoressa in
giurisprudenza e sono amante della moda
della musica del teatro e sono affetta
dalla genesi a del sacro ecco agenesia
del sacro una malattia rara che colpisce
circa 1 su 60 mila neonati bene quell 1
è capitato proprio a me un po come
vincere non so il superenalotto
quando sono nata i medici non mi davano
molte speranze di vita
anzi nessun medico avrebbe scommesso un
euro su di me proprio perché mi
ritenevano un caso troppo complesso
fortunatamente però grazie alla
caparbietà della mia famiglia
soprattutto di mia madre che qui
presente e di un medico in particolare
che decise di prendersi cura di me posso
dire oggi di essere ancora qui
quando ero piccolina dunque non ho
memoria di quel tempo valori viva
attraverso le parole di mia madre la
quale disse che quando il medico che
decise di prendersi cura di me mi vide
per la prima volta sia francia nel mio
port enfant e guardandomi nemi occhioni
blu disse ma tu sei proprio un bel
progetto di donna e tale ti faremo
diventare trent'anni dopo di cui 18
degli interventi chirurgici alle gambe
tantissimi anni passati in ospedale e
quasi venti centimetri in meno rispetto
alla media della mia statura
posso dire però che quel progetto di
donna oggi si è realizzato
io certo c'è anche da dire però che non
è semplice convivere con una disabilità
quando purtroppo si hanno dei limiti
oggettivi si fa fatica ad accettare se
stessi
non si senta non ci si sente adeguati e
come se rifiuto fosse dietro l'angolo
questo perché perché il mondo ci impone
specifici canoni di bellezza che poi io
mi chiedo ma chi decide cosa è bello o
perfetto essere una donna disabile non
significa perdere il desiderio di
sentirsi bella sexy femminile attraente
alla moda significa anzi accettare se
stesse ed amarsi oscar wilde diceva che
ad amare se stessi e l'inizio di una
storia d'amore lunga tutta una vita
ed è così noi non dobbiamo dobbiamo
imparare ad apprezzarci disabilità o
meno mi rivolgo anche a tutte le donne
che magari non si accettano per un
piccolo difetto fisico perché c'è
bisogno di autostima e l'autostima è un
po come un muscolo balenata giorno per
giorno
bisogna nutrire la nostra immagine
davanti allo specchio valorizzando i
pregi ma senza nascondere odiare qualche
difetto fisico neanche un difetto fisico
evidente come quello di una disabilità
che poi quello che la società definisce
difetto fondamentalmente fa parte di noi
e di conseguenza fa parte anche della
nostra bellezza yo yo
ecco cerco di abbattere queste di
stereotipi legati al mondo della
disabilità stereotipi anche di
compressione l'ipocrisia e io me ne sono
sempre resa conto che purtroppo questi
stereotipi esistono sia dagli sguardi
della gente fin da bambina ma crescendo
poi me ne sono resa conto soprattutto
dagli sguardi degli uomini quando sono
vi spiego il perché quando sono seduta
ad esempio ad un tavolino di un bar
oppure
sono in macchina al volante della mia
auto perché i disabili guidano mi capita
di essere osservata con gli occhi di un
di un uomo che ovviamente guarda una
bella ragazza una biondo platino e anche
poco appariscente però poi capita che
quando scendo dall'auto o magari mi
sposto dal tavolino del bar accompagnata
dalla mia sedia a rotelle oppure dalle
mie stampelle che vedere perché io anzi
le del mostro perché sono un accessorio
fashion leopardato però gli sguardi
cambiano e diventano sguardi incuriositi
di compassione come se chi sa quale
peccato avessero fatto a guardare una
donna disabile come se c'è un alone di
protezione attorno alle donne disabili
quell'alone di protezione che sia per le
donne per le persone fragili e bambini
come se una donna disabile non possa
esprimere seduzione e bellezza
io magari sarà coi capelli biondo
platino la pelle chiara agli occhi
chiari ma forse addirittura ad essere
accostata ad un angelo asessuato no vi
prego eccessivo quindi fortunatamente
però non tutti gli uomini sono uguali e
il mio ragazzo non ha mai abbassato lo
sguardo ha continuato a guardarmi come
si fa con ogni altra donna e chiamato
ecco andando oltre la mia disabilità e
il suo ripetermi ti amo dalla testa ai
piedi
mi libera dall'idea di non poterli
piacere abbastanza
ecco io però sono qui soprattutto perché
io cerco di abbattere questi stereotipi
attraverso il mondo che per antonomasia
celebra la perfezione e sto parlando del
mondo della moda
in un primo momento il binomio moda e
disabilità può sembrare insolito possono
sembrare può sembrare un accostamento
ecco assurdo azzardato un po non so come
la l'ananas sulla pizza
chi mai la mangerebbe eppure no il
binomio moda e disabilità è un binomio
perfetto credetemi io ne sono convinta
perché da qualche anno organizzo sfilate
di moda con ragazze e modelle quindi
professionisti anche mode e modelle con
diverse disabilità sono riusciti a
realizzare questo mio sogno grazie ad
associazioni che hanno creduto in me
grazie a stilisti che hanno deciso di
far indossare i propria
anche a una ragazza che magari non ebbe
metri ma è seduta ma è bello uguale vi
faccio vedere qualche foto
ecco questa è la sfilata l'ultima che
abbiamo organizzato ed è già una seconda
edizione
come vedete non c'è c'è l'abito è
bellissimo ma soprattutto il sorriso
delle modelle e stupendo ognuna poi con
una propria storia
dunque la disabilità non è contagiosa
l'ignoranza siano ha detto gli stilisti
quindi questo perché perché la sfilata
in fondo è un pretesto è un fatto
pretestuoso dietro ad ognuna di loro si
nasconde una storia fantastica non me le
posso raccontare tutta ma tutte ma
vorrei farvi giusto un esempio come la
storia di simona che non accettava il
proprio corpo perché è un corpo ecco uno
standardizzato ai canoni estetici quindi
non sa non accettava che la sua
disabilità fosse sul suo corpo però
quando viene a sapere che io l'avevo
scelta come modella
lei decise di intraprendere quel lungo
percorso di fisioterapia che invece lei
non accettava di fare quindi per me
questa era una giusta strada perché lei
comunque migliorata tantissimo oppure
come vari a lei e madre di un bambino
splendido perché sfatiamo anche questo
mito una donna disabile può diventare
anche madre e quando il suo figlio si
vergognava della sedia a rotelle della
madre davanti alla scuola però vedendo
la sfilare in passerella
il bambino è andato incontro alla mamma
abbracciandola e il giorno dopo non si
vergognava più della disabilità della
madre anzi ne era fiero orgoglioso
dicendo mia madre è una modella
quindi sono tante piccole storie che
però mi fanno capire che veramente è una
strada giusta quindi per abbattere i
cliché stereotipi su questa passerella
che io definisco una passerella
dell'inclusione dove a sfilare non c'è
c'è moda eleganza e bellezza c'è anche
disabilità ma non solo dunque io
in conclusione voglio dire che il tema è
il sono le onde il proprio l'onda quella
che io cerco di scaraventare con ogni
forza contro questi stereotipi e
pregiudizi
impariamo a guardare le persone con
disabilità con occhi diversi
impariamo a non provare più compassione
ma soltanto rispetto senza
superficialità perché la diversità
quella di ognuna di noi gambe storte o
meno disabilità o meno è quella che ci
rende unici e differenti gli uni dagli
altri
ed è un valore prezioso non credete al
conformismo che ci vuole tutti uguali
credete invece che a normale e cercare
di non avere difetti mentre normale
straordinario e chi ha il coraggio di
accettarsi e di amarsi nel bene e nel
male
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]